you reject the show this is a real
reason I watched the movie talks now we
understand you if you call the real Road
just because you reject everything else
but what you want yeah for real I'm John
Humphrey and welcome to the real rejects
this is John Roca this is John Roca
hello everyone is john andrew rose no
there's no internet steven douche Greg
would fit in I like just once I know you
Devo does not care he's that he's part
of the outlaw procrastination top ten
show the cinephiles podcast and the
outlaw nation
the last thing I'm out is
procrastination when I put out a tweet
for what should i watch with Roca a
couple people put out Darth al Jackson
yes from the title I'm assuming it's
dark Vader voiced by Samuel Jackson
check this out it's from seven years ago
action when this came the channel Taylor
Culbertson
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
plans are not aboard this ship no
transmissions were made escape during
the fight
[Music]
where's my baby your sad devotion to my
skin clearly has not helped you conjure
up the stolen data tapes or given you
clairvoyance enough to find the rebels
hidden
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
negotiators
[Music]
right oh dude that was brilliant that
wanted slip by my eyes that's a good one
so simple but so effective and perfect
lines were used like the lens they
perfectly fit into what the situation I
feel like there's a Sam Jackson line for
every conceivable scenario you would try
and make funny Sam Jackson has done so
many movies yeah yes so many movies I
feel like you could do the entire Star
Wars movie actually make this work that
was so freakin is my favorite always get
the [ __ ] anything like this and it's
gonna be great yeah break your
concentration of course something when
you do videos like this sometimes it's
like add it's just kind of funny because
they're in line but there are times
you're like that actually yeah really
well she's choking yeah it was crazy
hearing some reminds me like yeah I've
seen like most of these movies that I
recognize the quotes oh yeah that'd be
another game to play is like which
movies is from yeah absolutely which
line you know what I thought that should
be part of the Schmo down actually whoa
where you you like play a little bit of
an audio right and then you go what
movies is from yeah we played that game
sometimes on the smells no show yeah I
don't watch oh I don't get brought on
the schmoes no show oh we've been all
disposed no show the regex have been on
for one time so when you say you don't
get brought on you were lying I was
years ago
what was it really yeah all right that
should change that should change we
talked to Marcus on the phone hello and
Christians are just snobby okay others
every chance they get I don't like
anything you're saying I don't agree
with it they're good people I know how
to get to be on the schmoes now oh you
do yeah all about reverse psychology
yeah you get their egos yes you wound
their egos yeah just extreme nagging
until you know we get offered some kind
of you know grand deal to have our own
show
perfect for years I've been saying who
do you have to blow to get on schmoes
know this has been a dirty videos and I
realized it is why don't you get on down
there Greg why don't you discuss this
further with my baby the ruckus says on
social meds and masturbation this rose
blue nation and top seamen